if you take $74,000 for a genz z or
let's say they have a bachelor's degree
and they're 25 years old first of all
$74,000 is much higher than the average
income most genen zers are probably
making anywhere from 40 to 50 maybe 60
the average college monthly payment on a
loan is about 500 bucks you're down to
3,800 besides to split a two-bedroom
apartment in a medium-sized City like
Orlando so that their payment is 1,200 a
piece 200 for utility so400 now unless
they're going to have Lucky Charms and
peut butter and jelly their groceries
are going to cost about 600 bucks if
they're trying to get chicken beef and
some healthy stuff you have a 400 car
payment $200 Insurance $150 for gas $100
for a cell phone leaves you with 950
bucks but what if you decided to get an
extra job and pay off this debt you
would free up a car payment $400 and
free up $500 student loans so that's
$900 $600 for groceries for a single
person I think you can do it at 500 so
that's an extra hundred that you take
out so so there's an extra thousand so
that's really
$600 extra I think I think we're okay